THE SENATE BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE SUB FOR WILL
COME TO ORDER. GOOD MORNING AS
WE CONTINUE TO TAKE SOME
PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE ON GOING
COPE WITH NINETEEN RISKS THE
SENATE CONTINUES TO WELCOME THE
PUBLIC AND HAS PROVIDED ACCESS
TO BOTH IN PERSON AND
TELECONFERENCES THE PATIENT FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT VIA TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
THE PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT'S ALSO
GOING TO BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I'M GOING TO ANNOUNCE
IT NOW TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. 877-226-8163 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN THREE SIX
TWO EIGHT THREE THREE. I WILL
MAINTAINED DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO WAS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WE ARE
HOLDING OUR SUBCOMMITTEE ARE
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING HERE IN
THE- STREET BUILDING I ASK ALL
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE BE
PRESENT IN ROOM TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED SO WE CAN ESTABLISH OUR
QUORUM IN BEGINNER HEARING.
THOSE PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE TODAY ARE ALSO
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I ASK THAT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED YOU USE THE RAISE
YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO UN MUTE PLEASE
SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING. OUR I. T. PERSON NOW
WILL PUT YOU BACK ON YOU WHEN
YOU ARE DONE ONCE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU CAN
BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN. STATE
YOUR NAME AND THEN YOU ARE READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE HEARING ROOM TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. AND WE HAVE A
LITTLE ONE IN THE ROOM RIGHT
NOW. SO BE HEY PUBLIC COMMENT
WILL BE HEARD AFTER ALL
DISCUSSION ITEMS HAVE BEEN
PRESENTED BEFORE WE BEGIN. LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM MR HACKER
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. HERE YOUR
YOUR DOCTOR. OKAY THE CONSULTANT
NOTES THAT A QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED WE WILL BE
DISCUSSING ALL THE ISSUES LISTED
IN THE DISCUSSION SAYS SECTION
OF THE AGENDA TOGETHER AS A
REMINDER WE WILL BE TAKING ALL
VOTES ON BOTH THE VOTE ONLY
ITEMS ANY DISCUSSION ITEMS FOR
WHICH WE WILL BE TAKING A VOTE
AT THE CONCLUSION OF THE HEARING
AFTER ALL DISCUSSION AND ALL
PUBLIC COMMENT WE WILL BEGIN
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH AND ISSUE
ELEVEN OFFICE OF STRATEGIC
COMMUNICATIONS AND COMMUNITY
PARTNERS- P. ARE I'M ASSUMING
YOU'RE HEARING WOULD YOU LIKE TO
THE PRESENT. YES AND- THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR GOOD MORNING. AND
GOOD MORNING COMMUNITY MEMBERS-
SOME STUFF FONG DIRECTOR OF THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT OPS
BUDGET PROPOSAL OR THE- PROPOSED
OFFICE OF COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS
AND- STRATEGIC COMMUNICATIONS. I
JUST WANT TO SAY I'M JOINED HERE
ALSO THIS MORNING BY SCOTT
MORGAN MY CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR.
SONYA HARRIS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH. AND
STUFF FROM- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. AND I WANT TO KNOW
WHAT'S IN ADVANCE I IMPORT HAVE
TO LEAVE AT NOON TO RUN A
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL
QUARTERLY MEETING WHICH I CHAIR.
THIS WILL BE OUR FIRST IN PERSON
MEETING ESSENCE CORBETT AND- SO
BUT- I'LL HAVE ONE OF THE DEPUTY
SCOTT MORGAN WILL BE HERE. ON MY
BEHALF. D. AS SIXTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSAL BASED ON COSTS
FROM THE ESTATES- PREVIOUS
TWENTY TWENTY SENSES AND CORBETT
NINETEEN INITIATIVES. THAT WOULD
CREATE THE NEW OFFICE OF
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS AND
STRATEGIC COMMUNICATIONS WITHIN
ALL PR TO MANAGE THE STATE'S
HIGHEST PRIORITY PUBLIC
EDUCATION. AND COMMUNITY
COMMUNITY OUTREACH CAMPAIGNS TO
REACH CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES MORE EFFECTIVELY.
AND AS YOU KNOW AS PART OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY SENSES AND COVERT
NINETEEN OUTREACH AND PUBLIC
EDUCATION EFFORTS THE STATE
INVESTED- AND- INCREDIBLE
RESOURCES IN BUILDING CRITICAL
OUTREACH AND COMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR REACHING
COMMUNITIES THAT EXPERIENCED THE
HIGHEST SOCIAL AND HEALTH
INEQUITIES. I BELIEVE AS A
RESULT OF THAT I THINK
CALIFORNIA HAS DONE
SIGNIFICANTLY BETTER THAN MOST-
SPECIALLY ON THAT COVERS OFF
REACH BUT ALSO VERY ON THE
CENSUS. AS WELL. AS A RESULT OF
THAT PROCESS CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
ABLE TO TAKE AWAY MANY OF THE
BEST PRACTICES AND LESSONS
LEARNED SUCH AS THE NEED TO
CREATE A SUSTAINABLE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR CONSISTENT
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT. IN
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING THE GREATEST SOCIAL
INEQUITIES AND BUILD UPON THE
EFFORTS AND BUILD ON THE EFFORTS
OF TRUSTED MESSENGERS THE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
WHICH WE ARE NOW APPLYING IN THE
DEVELOPMENT. OF THE NEW OFFICE-
NOT BAD THAT IS FOR. AT A HIGH
LEVEL MODEL- FOR THE OFFICE IN.
SUB ONE SUPPORT OF A NETWORK OF
COMMUNITY PARTNERS THAT ARE
ORGANIZED AT THE REGIONAL AND
STATEWIDE LEVEL TO CREATE A
SUSTAINABLE INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
CONSISTENT ENGAGEMENT WITH
COMMUNITIES. THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING THE GREATEST SOCIAL
AND HEALTH INEQUITIES AND THEN
BUILDING ON THE EFFORTS OF
TRUSTED MESSENGERS OVER TIME AS
I MENTIONED SECOND THE USE OF
DATA INFORMED DECISION MAKING.
STRATEGY DEVELOPMENT AND FUNDING
ALLOCATIONS WOULD DRIVE MORE
TARGETED RESOURCES AND QUICKER
RESPONSE EFFORTS AND THEN THIRD
FACILITATING CLOSE COLLABORATION
ACROSS THE STATE DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES TO MAXIMIZE. THE REACH
AND IMPACT OF RESOURCES IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES WITH THE HIGHEST
INEQUITIES ENSURING AND A CLEAR
UNIFIED STATEWIDE APPROACH WITH
MESSAGING THAT IS RELIABLE.
ACTIONABLE AND BASED. ON THE
STATE'S MOST CURRENT
INFORMATION. THE PROPOSAL OFFICE
WOULD PROVIDE A HOLISTIC
APPROACH TO ADDRESSING PRIORITY
ISSUES BRINGING ALL CAMPAIGN
EFFORTS TOGETHER UNDER ONE
UMBRELLA TO OPERATE IN AN
EFFECTIVE MANNER. APPLYING THAT
MODEL IN INFRASTRUCTURE
DEVELOPED UNDER THE TWENTY
TWENTY CENSUS AND CALL THE
NINETEEN OUTREACH. EFFORTS WILL
HELP STRENGTHEN COORDINATION
ACROSS THE STATE AND ENSURE
IMPROVE SERVICE DELIVERY. WE
EXPECT THE OFFICE STUPID
MULTIPLE PROGRAMMATIC
EFFICIENCIES ULTIMATELY
CONTRIBUTING TO BETTER OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY AND ON OVERALL
GREATER CAPACITY TO GET
INFORMATION TO WHO AND WHERE IT
IS MOST NEEDED. OUR PLAN IS TO
WORK WITH STATE PARTNERS
INCLUDING GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS
KNOWN AS GOV OFFICE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
OR DGS TO BETTER LEVERAGE
EXISTING PROCUREMENT MODELS AND
EXPLORE WHAT INNOVATIVE
CONTRACTING MODELS ARE
AVAILABLE. WHILE AT THE SAME
TIME I'M ALLEVIATING SOME OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS AND
BARRIERS THAT HAVE BEEN CITED BY
COMMUNITY PARTNERS THROUGHOUT
OUR EXPERIENCE ESPECIALLY OVER
THE LAST- THREE YEARS. AND BY
BUILDING UP ON THE MODEL IN
INFRASTRUCTURE BEST PRACTICES
AND LESSONS LEARNED FROM- THE
RECORDED IN CENSUS THE NEW
OFFICE WILL HELP COORDINATE A
COMMUNITY COMMUNITY FOCUSED
PRACTICE WITH STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS ALLOWING US TO
REALISE CROSS PROMOTIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES. THE AND
EFFICIENCIES AND I CREATE A
VENUE TO SHARE BEST PRACTICES-
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY- I BELIEVE
INSTITUTIONALIZING PARTNERSHIPS
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE TRUSTED
BY COMMUNITIES WE SERVE
SPECIALLY VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
WITH THE HISTORY OF GOVERNMENT
MISTRUST I BELIEVE WILL HELP.
TRANSFORM THE PRACTICE OUR OWN
PRACTICE OF THE STATE AND OUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WHILE ALSO
CREATING A VENUE- TO SHARE. BEST
PRACTICES THAT ARE ROOTED IN
CULTURAL HUMILITY AND THAT'S
KIND OF THE- HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW
OF THE PURPOSE. OF THIS OFFICE-
AND I WILL BE HAPPY AND MY STAFF
AND DEPARTMENT FINANCE. MENTAL
STUFF WHO ARE HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY AND-
WE'LL BE HAPPY. TO TAKE YOUR
QUESTIONS GREAT THANK YOU
FINANCE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PROVIDE ANY COMMENT. GOOD
MORNING KEVIN CLARK DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU L. A. O.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PROVIDE ANY
COMMENT- THIS SPRING WEATHER FOR
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND AS WE PREVIOUSLY NOTED AT
THE FEBRUARY NINTH SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARING. THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
IDENTIFIED A LEGITIMATE NEED TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND TO BETTER
COORDINATE THE STATE'S DISTRICT
PUBLIC OUTREACH EFFORTS. HOWEVER
WE ALSO RAISED A NUMBER OF
CONCERNS REGARDING PROPOSAL'S
LACK OF DETAILS AND IN
PARTICULAR THE BUDGET PROPOSAL
DID NOT PROVIDE A CLEAR
JUSTIFICATION FOR THE AMOUNT
THAT IS BEING REQUESTED AND THE
ADMINISTRATION WAS NOT AT THAT
TIME. ABLE TO CLEARLY ARTICULATE
HOW IT WOULD. SPECIFICALLY USE
THE REQUESTED FUNDING TO COST
EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS- SPECIFIC
OUTREACH. THANK YOU WE WILL NOW
OPEN THE DISCUSSION OF QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
VICE CHAIR NIELSEN. BY MAY
INQUIRED AS WE BEGIN THIS. THE
GOVERNOR AND HIS BUDGETS. IN
PARTICULAR THIS ONE. HAS GREATLY
EXPANDED GOVERNMENT. THIS MADE
THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL MAY BE
VIEWED AS A CONSOLIDATION. BUT
WE'RE ADDING A LOT OF P. WEISS.
AGENCY BY AGENCY DEPARTMENT OF A
DEPARTMENT GRADING IN FACT NEW
AGENCIES. NOW THE DIRECTOR
COMMENTED ABOUT THE I. T. THIS
IS ONE OF THE MOST EGREGIOUS.
FAILURES CALIFORNIA HISTORY.
WE'RE SPEND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ON IT UPGRADES THAT HAVEN'T WORK
. THAT WERE NOT DELIVERED ON
TIME. COULD YOU HAVE SOMEONE
THERE TELL ME WHAT IS GOING TO
BE BETTER NOW. AND UNDERSTAND
DON'T OFFERED TO ME THE OFFICE
OF INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY OR
WHATEVER IT'S CALLED TODAY THE
ONLY MAJOR ACCOMPLISHMENT THAT
AGENCIES WHICH CHANGES NAME
SEVERAL TIMES. WHATEVER IT'S
CALLED NOW ARE THEY STILL GOING
TO BE THE ONE TO MONITOR OUR
CONTRACTS ARE THEY ONES WHO WILL
ENSURE THAT IF THE PROVIDERS DO
NOT DELIVER. TIMELY ORDER
FAILURES THAT THERE ARE
CONSEQUENCES FOR THE PROVIDERS
CONSUMERS AND GIVE ME A LITTLE
BIT OF COMFORT THAT WE'RE GONNA
QUIT SQUANDERING BILLIONS OF
TAXPAYER DOLLARS ON FOLLIES LIKE
FISCALE WHICH WILL BE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY. CAN ANYONE RESPOND
TO THAT. AND MAYBE I WOULD ALSO
LIKE THE LET JEM LIST BECAUSE I
KNOW THEY HAVE VOICE SOME
CONCERNS. ZERO THANK YOU SENATOR
FOR THAT QUESTION IN TERMS OF
THE- SORRY IN TERMS OF THE- LOAD
. BE IMPROVED THROUGH THIS
PROCESS I THINK YOU NOTED ON IT
IN THE IN THE BEGINNING I THINK
ONE OF THE PRIMARY OBJECTIVE IS
A HOW TO CONSOLIDATE MULTIPLE
FUNCTIONS THAT ACTUALLY TAKES
PLACE WITHIN STATE GOVERNMENTS-
SPECIFIC TO OUTREACH AND
COMMUNICATION ON- HIGH PRIORITY
ISSUES WE DO BELIEVE THAT
CONSOLIDATION AND COORDINATION
ACROSS THE STATE AGENCIES FOR
EXAMPLE THE STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL THAT I MENTIONED THAT I
WILL BE. CHAIR THAT I CHAIR AS
SEVEN STATE AGENCIES THIS OFFICE
- INTENDED TO ARCHERY OF CLOSE
COORDINATION WITH BILLS THAT
AGENCIES AS WELL SPECIFIC TO
CONTRACTING- WE WORK OBVIOUSLY
WITH- GOV OFFICE AS I MENTIONED
AND- THE LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. AGENCY- THEY-
MANAGE AND COORDINATE A LOT OF
CON BETTER ALASKA SCOTT MORGAN-
WHICH DEPUTY. TO ODD- TO RESPOND
SOME OF YOUR PRESS RATHER TO CON
THE- THANK REALLY EXAMPLE. YEAH
THAT'S YOU THIS PROPOSAL THE
HANG A- AND I TO. APPROVAL
PROCESS DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
SO THEY WOULD NOT BE YOU KNOW
SIGNING OFF ON ON THE CONTRACTS
THAT THAT WE WOULD BE
PARTICIPATING IN WITH WITH
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS-
WE WOULD BE WORKING WITH NEED U.
S. DEPARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES
ON THAT SO. I CAN'T ANSWER
SPECIFICALLY ON NO I. T. ISSUES
AND PAST EFFORTS BY THE
TECHNOLOGY BUT BUT THIS PROPOSAL
DOESN'T HAVE A THEY HAVE THE I.
T. COMPONENT THAT WOULD REQUIRE
THE APPROVAL PROCESS THROUGH
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY. WE'LL
PLACE STILL. THE NEED FOR THIS
IN GOVERNMENT AND WE DO NOT HAVE
IT. AND THEY CANNOT CONVINCE ME
BUT ANYWAY THAT THEY HAVE. IT'S
TIME TO DO THAT JUST CONVEY THAT
MESSAGE AND I THANK YOU FOR THE
ANSWER. THANK YOU WILL BE A.
FIFTY AND- THE SPRING WEATHER
FORD WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WILL FOLLOW UP
WITH YOUR ON STAFF ON- IF
THERE'S- REQUEST WE CAN HELP YOU
WITH WITH REGARDS THE
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY-
CONTRACTING I'M QUESTIONS THEY
MIGHT HAVE YES LESSEN THE
ARRANGE SUCH A MEETING THANK YOU
. IS THAT IT SENATE ALSO FOR YOU
OKAY GREAT THANK YOU SENATOR RON
. I'M OKAY I GUESS I JUST HAVE A
QUESTION- A QUICK QUESTION-
REFERENCING THAT NEED TO. BE
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THAT IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR THE STATE TO BE
WORKING WITH TRUSTED PARTNERS.
I'M THE DO TRUSTED PARTNERS I
KNOW THEY INCLUDE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS COULD THEY
ALSO INCLUDE- PARTNERSHIPS WITH
THE FAITH BASED COMMUNITY THAT
ALSO DO HAVE FIVE OH ONE C.
THREES AND ARE DOING LOTS OF
WORK IN THE COMMUNITY. FIGURE
MANAGER FOR THE QUESTION I'M
GONNA ASK OF SONYA. HARRIS WHO
HAS BEEN SIGNIFICANTLY ENGAGE
WITH THE CBO THROUGH THE-
COALBED PROCESS AND TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION. THANK YOU SO MUCH
STRICTER THANK YOU SENATOR FOR
ALL QUESTION- ON YOUR ANSWER
ABSOLUTELY YES THAT THE RANGE OF
THE DEFINITION IN TERMS OF
TRUSTED MESSENGERS PRIME I'M
JUST BECAUSE YOU BRING UP
ANYTHING I'M MORE. YEAH AYE WE
REACHED CAME OFF- F. AROUND I'M
BACK TO CHIU. I'M REALLY FOR.
AND AFTER AMERICAN POWER MAKING
. I HELPED BRING FROM HOOVER
NINE CHURCHES NINE OKAY IS A
MULTIPLE TO GO TO HELP US KICK
ARE NOT EASTERN. PARKWAY MORE
WARMER FOR HE NUMBER TOGETHER
HEALTH AND WELLNESS. ONE PM WILL
BE FOR IN ADDITION BEEN ABLE TO
WORK WITH AND CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE AND BUSINESS. AND
WHETHER THAT BE THROUGH THE
PHONE. I'M MORE THROUGH THE THAT
WE'RE DOING TO REALLY LONG WITH
NORMAN PARK AND- TALKING AND SO
. NEED TO BE.
R. F. P. TO SAY THIS IS
SOMETHING WE WANT TO DO ARE
THESE GROUPS THAT ARE ON
RETAINER. FOR THE FULL DURATION
OF THIS RELATIONSHIP- BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY YOU WANT TO HAVE A
POOL. OF VENDORS OR CONTRACTORS
THAT ARE DIVERSE BUT I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS ARE THEY SORT OF
LOCKED IN OR DO THEY SORT OF
TAPPED IN WHEN THEY WANT TO
BASED ON IF THEY THINK THAT
THERE'S- A COMPATIBILITY.
BETWEEN WHAT THEY'RE ABLE TO
CONTRIBUTE AND HOW THEY'RE ABLE
TO HELP AND THE PROJECT NEED AT
HAND. I'M GONNA ASK SONYA
RESPOND TO THAT AS WELL. OF
COURSE THANK YOU FOR EVERYTHING
HE HAS CONTEMPLATED IN THE
PROPOSAL IT WOULD BE THEM THE
LATTER IS THAT THE TWO OPTIONS
THAT YOU PROVIDED CENTER
COMMUNITY TRYING TO MEET
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. HE ADDED
INFORMATION BLACKROCK THINKING.
THEM BY HELPING TO LEVERAGE
EXISTING PROCUREMENT MODELS
PERHAPS SOMETHING LIKE A MASTER
SERVICE AGREEMENT WE CAN
UNDERSTAND WHAT GEOGRAPHIES THAT
PARTICULAR CBO MIGHT HAVE WHAT
LANGUAGE PROFICIENCIES AS AN
EXAMPLE. AND THEN WHEN THE
OFFICE YOU DIDN'T HAVE A NEED A
COULD PUT FORWARD YOU. KNOW EACH
TIME. YOU KNOW AS A GAMBLE
WORKING WITHOUT BACK THE NATION
. IN THIS. YEAH YOU YEAR IS HELP
US- STONE RIGHT- CORMAC. CAN YOU
KNOW PUTTING ON A CAN EVENT.
GREAT THANK YOU. OKAY I'M- THAT
I IS A HOLD OPEN IN WE'RE NOW
GONNA MOVE ON A TWELVE CAL CLIMB
ACTION STATE SIR PRO- PR WOULD
YOU LIKE TO PRESENT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS JOSH
FRIDAY IN THE CHIEF SERVICE
OFFICER AND OUR OFFICE
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS. OVERSEAS
SERVICE AND VOLUNTEER
OPPORTUNITIESTHROUGHOUT THE
STATE WITH THE GOAL TO UNITE
DEMOBILIZED TO ENGAGE
CALIFORNIANS IN SERVICE TO TAKE
ACTION AND- MAKE CHANGE AND
CONNECT WITH EACH OTHER SO THAT
WE CAN TACKLE OUR BIGGEST
CHALLENGES TOGETHER. SO AS WE
ALL FOCUSED ON THE EXISTENTIAL
CRISIS OF CLIMATE CHANGE. THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE ACTION FOR
BUDGET PROPOSAL SEEKS TO MAKE
ONGOING A LIMITED TERM
INVESTMENT OF THREE POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS. INTO
PROGRAMMATIC CLIMATE PROGRAMS.
THIS INVESTMENT IS GOING TO
ALLOW CALIFORNIA TO SUSTAIN THE
NATION'S LEADING PROGRAM ON
CLIMATE ACTION. WHICH HAS BEEN
DESCRIBED AS A MODEL FOR THE
COUNTRY AS THE IDEA OF THIS
NATIONAL CIVILIAN CLIMATE COURSE
STARTS TO BUILD MOMENTUM. THE
CLIMATE ACTION CORPS LEVERAGES
FEDERAL AMERICORPSFUNDING AND
WHILE THIS PROGRAM IS STILL IN
ITS EARLY STAGES. THE INTEREST
HAS REALLY BEEN SUBSTANTIAL WITH
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE PEOPLE
APPLYING THAT WE HAVE POSITIONS
TO FILL. OVER THE LAST YEAR THAT
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE ACTION CORPS
HAS DEPLOYED OVER THREE HUNDRED
FELLOWS IN FRONTLINE COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE. INCLUDING
IN MANY COMMUNITIES YOU ALL
REPRESENT THESE FELLOWS RECEIVE
A STIPEND AND A SCHOLARSHIP TO
COLLEGE AS WELL AS INVALUABLE
PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE. AND
THEY ALSO RECRUITED ENGAGED OVER
TEN THOUSAND VOLUNTEERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. RESULTING
IN THOUSANDS OF VOLUNTEER HOURS
FOR ITS CLIMATE ACTION. THIS
PROGRAM IN THE FELLOWS HAVE
FOCUSED THEIR WORK LARGELY IN
THREE MAIN AREAS. URBAN
GREENING. ORGANIC WASTE AND FOOD
RECOVERY AND WILDFIRE RESILIENCY
AND JUST EIGHTY ILLUSTRATE THIS
WORK QUICKLY. SEVEN SENATOR COME
ON OR IN YOUR DISTRICT CLIMATE
CORPS FELLOWS HAVE SUPPORTED FOR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO
DO A TREE PLANTING PROGRAM.
BECAUSE WE KNOW WITH OUR CLIMATE
ACTION CORPS THAT THE LACK OF
TREES. AND CANOPY IN CERTAIN.
COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY THOSE
AFFECTED BIKES THREE HE- IS OF
THE CLIMB ISSUE. BUT IT IS ALSO
A SOCIAL AND RACIAL JUSTICE
ISSUE THAT OUR FELLOWS ARE
TAKING HEAD ON. AND WE KNOW IN
SENATOR COVER YEAR WAS DISTRICT
THAT WE HAVE A PROGRAM WHERE
FELLOWS HAVE RUN A LARGE SCALE
FOOD RECOVERY. OPERATION TO MAKE
SURE THAT FOOD DOESN'T JUST END
UP IN A LANDFILL WHICH OF COURSE
WE ALL KNOW HAS A SIGNIFICANT
CLIMATE CONSEQUENCE. BUT THEY
ALSO MAKE SURE THAT THE FOOD
GETS TO FOOD INSECURE PEOPLE WHO
NEED IT THE MOST. AND IN
ADDITION CENTER NIELSEN IN YOUR
DISTRICT WE HAVE FELLOWS
CURRENTLY WORKING TODAY IN BUTTE
COUNTY WITH NEIGHBORHOODS AND
COMMUNITY PARTNERS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE COMMUNITIES ARE MORE
WILDFIRES ILYIN. AND SENATOR ROB
IS YOU KNOW WE ARE DOING
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF SERVICE
WORK IN YOUR AREA AS WELL SO
THIS PROGRAM HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL
IT'S ALREADY LAUNCHED SEVERAL
CAREERS OF YOUNG PEOPLE INTO
SUSTAINABILITY WORK. ITSELF PAY
DOWN STUDENT DEBT. AND IT'S
HELPING CALIFORNIA CHIEF ARE
VERY AMBITIOUS CLIMATE GOALS. SO
THE GOAL OF THIS REQUEST IS TO
BUILD ON THE MOMENTUM OF THE
CURRENT PROGRAM TO ENSURE THAT
THERE ARE NO FUTURE FUNDING GAPS
IN PROGRAMMING OPERATIONS. AS A
RESULT OF THE FEDERAL AMERICORPS
FUNDING THAT WE NEED TO SECURE.
AND TO ENSURE THE CONTINUITY AND
SUSTAINABILITY OF THIS
GROUNDBREAKING PROGRAM SO WE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
AND CONSIDERATION AND- ARE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FINANCE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PROVIDE ANY COMMENT. THERE AGAIN
KEVIN BURKE WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THIS TIME. OKAY GREAT
L. A- WOULD YOU LIKE TO PROVIDE
ANY COMMENT. RYAN RUTHERFORD
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND WE JUST WANTED TO-
REITERATE AS WE PREVIOUSLY NOTED
IN THE EVERY NIGHT SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARING THAT- ONGOING PROVIDING
ONGOING FUNDING TO THE CLIMATE
ACTION COURSE SEEMS FROM TRIP
THIS TIME. THANK YOU WE WILL NOW
OPEN THE DISCUSSION OF QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
VICE CHAIR SENATOR NELSON.
SENATOR ROTH. OKAY I THINK I'M
JUST GOING TO ECHO THAT
CONTINUED- QUESTION ABOUT RIGHT
WHY RIGHT NOW I'M RATHER THAN
NEXT YEAR AND WHY THE NEED FOR
ON GOING FUNDING. THANK YOU
SENATOR AGAIN THE REASON FOR
BRINGING THIS FORTH NOW IS TO
ENSURE THAT AS WE BUILD MOMENTUM
FOR THIS PROGRAM WHICH IS WE'RE
SEEING ENORMOUS SUCCESS AROUND.
THAT THERE ARE NO FUNDING GAPS
IN THE FUTURE- FOR PROGRAMMATIC
OPERATIONS AS A RESULT OF THE
FEDERAL AMERICORPS FUNDING THAT
WE HAVE TO SECURE IN ORDER TO
MAKE THE PROGRAM POSSIBLE. OKAY
GREAT AS YOU ALL KNOW THIS IS A
HOLD OPEN ITEM SO WE ARE GOING
TO. MOVE ON TO THE NEXT ITEM.
OUT WE ARE NOW GOING TO MOVE ON
TO ANYONE WANTING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT REGARDING ITEMS
ON THE AGENDA. OKAY REPUBLICAN
AT THE END. NOW OUR PARENTS
WOULDN'T GO RIGHT TO THE- TO THE
VOTE WE DEVOTE ONLY CAN DEVOTE
ONLY AND THEN. WORKING FOR THE
AREA I BET THIS WITH THE- YEAH
KINDA OKAY WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON I
ISSUE ITEM THIRTEEN ENCAMPMENT
REMEDIATION GRANT- WHO'S ARE.
WOULD YOU ARE YOU HERE TO
PRESENT YOU READY. GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE YES I'M
READY OKAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
IT'S MY PLEASURE TO COME BEFORE
YOU AGAIN I'M VICTOR ON THE
GRANTS DIRECTOR OF REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA INTERAGENCY
COUNCIL ON HOMELESSNESS UNDER
THE BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES
AND HOUSING. AND I APPRECIATE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY ON OUR
REQUEST FOR A FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND APPROPRIATION. AND
ACCOMPANYING TRAILER BILL
CHANGES TO PROVIDE LOCAL
ENTITIES ACROSS THE STATE- WITH
GRANTS IN SUPPORT OF PERMANENT
HOUSING SOLUTIONS FOR
CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCING
UNSHELTERED HOMELESSNESS. AND
FOR RESOLVING ENCAMPMENTS SITES
ACROSS THE STATE. SO AS YOU'RE
ALL AWARE THIS REQUEST TO BUILD
UPON THE FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
ONE TIME ENCAMPMENT RESOLUTION
PROGRAM THAT WAS ESTABLISHED FOR
THIS FISCAL YEAR AND WHICH WE
ARE CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS OF
IMPLEMENTING. IN THIS FIRST
GENERATION OF THE PROGRAM WE
RECEIVE REQUESTS FOR ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS. IN
FUNDING. FOR PROPOSALS FROM
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
COMMUNITY MEMBERS LIVING IN CAP
SO- MORE THAN DOUBLE THE AMOUNT
OF MONEY THAT WAS APPROPRIATED.
IN ADDITION WE HEARD FROM MANY
JURISDICTIONS THAT EXPRESSED
THAT HAD MORE FUNDING THAN
AVAILABLE THEY WOULD HAVE
SUBMITTED MULTIPLE PROPOSALS AS
YOU KNOW THERE ARE. YOU KNOW
THERE'S JUST ONE CAP IN ANY
GIVEN JURISDICTIONS AND MANY OF
OUR- ORDERS ACROSS THE STATE
SAID THAT THEY WOULD NEED BIGGER
ASKS AND MULTIPLE ASKS HAD THE
RESOURCES BEEN AVAILABLE- THIS
NEED FOR A MUCH LARGER SCALE
PROGRAM IS FURTHER REFLECTED IN
THE MOST RECENT POINT IN TIME
COUNT OF PEOPLE EXPERIENCING.
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA I'M
WHICH DEMONSTRATED THAT ABOUT
TWO THIRDS OF CALIFORNIANS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS- ARE
IN I'M SHELTER SETTING SUCH AS
ENCAMPMENTS ACROSS THE STATE
THAT'S OVER ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS THE HIGHEST NUMBER
OF UNSHELTERED. INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IN THE
NATION- SO THIS REQUEST WILL
ALLOW US TO FURTHER INVEST IN
FLEXIBLE INNOVATIVE AND TARGETED
IN CAMDEN RESOLUTION STRATEGIES
AT THE SCALE AND WITH THE
URGENCY THAT'S NEEDED TO ADDRESS
THIS PROBLEM- SO WITH THAT HI
AND WELCOME QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU AYE FINANCE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO COMMENT. READ
SOME SOME APARTMENTS FINANCED
NOTHING TO ADD AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU L. A. O. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO COMMENT. THANK YOU
MEMBERS NOTICED WHEN I LEFT WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL AUGMENTATION FOR THE
ATTACHMENT MEDIATION PROGRAM
MANY ORDERS OF MAGNITUDE ABOVE
WHAT HAPPENED PREVIOUSLY
AUTHORIZED FOR THE PROGRAM. AT
THE TIME THAT WE RELEASED OUR
ANALYSIS OF THE JANUARY PROPOSAL
HE HAD NO INFORMATION ABOUT HOW
THE ORIGINAL FIFTY MILLION HAVE
ALLOCATED. WAS BEING USED AS A
RESULT WE CANNOT ASSESS THE
PERFORMANCE OF THE PROGRAM AT
THAT TIME SINCE THEN THE
MINISTRATION HAS ANNOUNCED
AWARDS FOR THE PROGRAM THE
QUESTIONS INCLUDED IN THE AGENDA
BY THE STAFF ARE APPROPRIATE AND
CONSISTENT WITH OUR SUGGESTION
OF THE LEGISLATURE DEDICATE SOME
TIME. THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS
NOTHING HOW IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE ORIGINAL ALLOCATION IS GOING
FOR MAKING DECISIONS ABOUT. THE
PROPOSED DOCUMENTATION THANK YOU
. YOU'RE NEVER GOING TO BRING A
BACK TO OF THE- VICE CHAIR
NELSON DO YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
. SENATOR ROB DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. OKAY I'M MIKE JUST
ONE QUESTION IS- IF YOU COULD
SHARE WHAT OUTCOMES YOU EXPECT
ICY AGE TO SEE FROM THESE
PROJECTS. FOR THE ORIGINAL FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR APPROPRIATIONS.
SO THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION-
WE WERE ABLE TO FIND NINETEEN
PROPOSALS- ACROSS THE STATE AND
WE WERE REALLY PLEASED TO SEE
THE DIVERSE REPRESENTATION IN
THE PROPOSALS THAT WERE GRANTED
WE HAD RURAL URBAN AND SUBURBAN
MORE THAN SOUTHERN INLAND
COASTAL AND SUPPORT FOR
ENCAMPMENTS RANGING FOR UP TO
TWO HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS ON SOME
OF THE OUTCOMES THAT WE HOPE TO
SEE IN THE COMING MONTHS. ARE
COLLECTIVELY THESE PROJECTS SEEK
TO PROVIDE SHELTER AND A PATH TO
PERMANENT HOUSING FOR OVER
FOURTEEN HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING UNSHELTERED
HOMELESSNESS AND THESE PROJECTS
ALSO SEEK TO RESTORE
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY DIFFERENT
SITES TO THEIR INTENDED USE
AFTER THE INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE
BEEN RESIDING THERE ARE
TRANSITION TO SHELTER AND THEN A
PATH TO PERMANENT HOUSING- IN
ADDITION WE'RE BRINGING ON A
RESEARCH AND EVALUATION
CONTRACTOR WHO WORK WITH US AND
I DO CLOSE STUDY OF THESE
PROPOSALS AND FUTURE PROGRAMS
THAT WE BRING ON THE LINE. TO
HELP US IDENTIFY WHAT ARE THE
MOST EFFECTIVE STRATEGIES AND
WHAT ARE THEIR STRATEGIES THAT
CAN BE AMPLIFIED SHARED AND
REPLICATED ACROSS THE STATE SO
WE HAVE BOTH IMMEDIATE. I WOULD
COME THAT WAY LOOKING AT IN
TERMS OF. THE OF. HOMELESSNESS
RATED WHO ARE CURRENTLY ON THE
STREETS BUT ALSO LOOKING AT DOWN
THE ROAD- SYSTEMIC SYSTEM CHANGE
PRODUCTS THAT WE CAN BRING TO
BEAR. AND SO HOW IS THIS- HOW
WILL THESE IN CAN'T RESOLUTION
GRANTS BE DIFFERENT BE BETTER.
BENEFIT IN A DIFFERENT WAY THAN
HAPP. SO THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION- THE HALF PROGRAM IS.
FOR PARTICULAR JURISDICTIONS TO
SUPPORT THEIR HOMELESSNESS
RESPONSE SYSTEM OVERALL. WHEREAS
THIS PROGRAM IS TARGETED FOR
SPECIFIC LOCATIONS- TO SERVICE
SPECIFIC INDIVIDUALS SO IT'S A
MUCH MORE TARGETED APPROACH- SO
YOU KNOW OTHER PROGRAMS LIKE CAP
. THEY ARE SYSTEMS LEVEL
SUPPORTS WHERE HAS THE IN CAMERA
SOLUTION FUND AND THIS PROPOSED
FUNDING WOULD PROVIDE FLEXIBLE
BUT TARGETED FUNDS THAT CAN BE
TAILORED TO MEET THE SPECIFIC
NEEDS OF THE SPECIFIC
INDIVIDUALS AND THE SPECIFIC
LOCATION- THAT THE PROPOSAL
WHICH SEEK TO SUPPORT. AND THAT
WOULD RESULT IN. ENCAMPMENTS
SIDE BEING RESTORED TO ITS
INTENDED USE AFTER THE
INTERVENTIONS CONDUCTED. OKAY
GREAT THANK YOU FOR THAT- THIS
ITEM IS A HOLD OPEN WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GO TO ISSUE FOURTEEN- I
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY WORK LOAD
SUPPORT- IS D. F. C. H. ON THE
LINE I SEE YOU ARE YOU READY TO
PRESENT. WE ARE. HEADED MORNING
MR WOMAN DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS I
AM MIKE MILLER DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES WITH
A PART OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING THIS PROPOSAL INCLUDES
THREE POSITIONS FOR INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SERVICES DIVISION TO
SUPPORT MULTIPLE EFFORTS
INCLUDING KEY DATA REPORTING
ENFORCEMENT UNDER SB NINE
SEVENTY THREE OUR ONLINE
CUSTOMER SERVICE SUPPORT SYSTEM
STATEWIDE TELEWORK SUPPORT AND
TO ADDRESS MULTIPLE PRIVACY AND
SECURITY FINDINGS AUDITED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY AND THE CALIFORNIA
MILITARY DEPARTMENT JOINING ME
TODAY IS THE OF EACH CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR MERRY WEEK AND
WE ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER. ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE. OKAY GREAT-
FINANCE ANY COMMENTS. GOOD
MORNING AND YOU MARKET THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOTHING
FURTHER. HELLO ANY COMMENTS.
WITH WITH WITH THE ONLY- NO
COMMENTS TO HAPPEN THIS PROPOSAL
THANK YOU OKAY GRAHAM AND BRING
IT BACK TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE VICE CHAIR NIELSEN DO
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. OKAY SENATOR ROTH NO
QUESTIONS OKAY WELL YOU THIS IS
GOING TO BE APPROVED AS BUDGET
SO YOU HAVE LOCKED OUT MR MILLER
THE LOTTO TODAY I LAST ITEM.
JUST FOR THAT ONE THOUGH IS
ISSUE NUMBER FIFTEEN ENFORCEMENT
INVESTIGATION AND CONCILIATION
ENHANCEMENTS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT. ABSOLUTELY SO OUR
SECOND PROPOSAL REQUEST
RESOURCES TO DECREASE WAIT TIMES
FOR INVESTIGATIVE APPOINTMENTS
AND TO INCREASE THE RATE OF
CONCILIATION AND SETTLEMENTS
WITH OUR ENFORCEMENT DIVISION
RELATED T BOTH EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING COMPLAINTS. HISTORICALLY
THE TYPICAL AVERAGE WAIT TIME
BETWEEN THE INTAKE OF A
COMPLAINT IN THE INVESTIGATIVE
INTERVIEW IS APPROXIMATELY THREE
MONTHS LAST YEAR THE DEPARTMENT
EXPERIENCED A SURGE IN
COMPLAINTS THAT INCREASED WAIT
TIMES AND EMPLOYMENT. FROM THREE
MONTHS TO FOUR MONTHS AND IN
HOUSING FROM THREE MONTHS TO SIX
MONTHS. WE BELIEVE THAT THESE
COMPLAINTS INCREASE
SUBSTANTIALLY DUE TO THE
RECOVERY OF THE LABOR MARKET AND
WITH THE IMPENDING EXPLORATIONS
OF VARIOUS STATE LOCAL AND
FEDERAL INFECTION MORATORIUMS
DESIGNED TO PROTECT TENANTS
DURING THE COVERED NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. WAIT TIMES IN BOTH
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING HAVE
DECREASED AGAIN TO APPROXIMATELY
THREE MONTHS OVERALL THROUGH THE
USE OF OUT OF CLASSES CITING ITS
STRATEGIC OVERTIME AND
RECRUITMENT OF RETIRED NEW
INTENSE. THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
ALLOW US TO BE CREASED AWAY TIME
FROM THREE MONTHS TO ONE MONTH
AN INCREASE THE NUMBER OF CASES
OUR INVESTIGATORS ARE ABLE TO
CONCILIATE OR SETTLE. AGAIN
CHANGING IS VERY WEAK D. V. D.
F. EACH CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR OR
HAPPY TO HELP ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT. GREAT THANK
YOU FOR THAT- FINANCE DO YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. GREAT
MORNING I'M SORRY- AND YOU MIGHT
AGAIN WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NOTHING FURTHER THAT ON
THE PROPOSAL OKAY LA- DO YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS. NO COMMENTS
FROM ONLY OWNS WILL THINK YOU
OKAY GREAT I'M GONNA BRING IT
BACK TO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
VICE CHAIR NIELSEN. SIR CAN YOU
TELL ME WHAT YOU ARE DOING TO
TRACK THE SUCCESS. YOU'RE
PUTTING SOMETHING IN PLACE WELL
DONE SENATOR NIELSEN WE WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT YOUR MICROPHONE
IS ON IS IT. THOUGHT IT WAS OKAY
I WAS ENQUIRING D. WHAT
PROTOCOLS WHAT PROCEDURES DO YOU
HAVE IN PLACE TO TRACK THE
SUCCESS. DO YOU HAVE ANY
PARTICULAR BENCHMARKS OR
SCHEDULES FOR- IMPERATIVES THAT
HAVE TO BE MATH. THE TRIBUNAL
NUMBERS OF CONTACTS IN OF POLICE
DEPLOYED. BY SUCCESS DO YOU
MEAN- BUT OUT COMES OR NOT I
MEAN OUTCOME SIR. OH WAIT THAT
MIGHT BE I DON'T KNOW IF MAYBE
IT MIGHT BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THAT
ONE- WE DO HAVE OUR BENCHMARKS
WE HAVE AN ANNUAL REPORT THAT WE
SUBMITS- EVERY YEAR THAT-
CATALOGS WHERE- COMPLAINTS COME
FROM- WHAT TYPES OF COMPLAINTS
THEY ARE- HOW LONG CASES TAKE TO
RESOLVE- WE- WE DEFINITELY DO
KEEP TRACK OF- WHAT TYPES OF
COMPLAINTS WE RECEIVED HOW LONG
THEY TAKE TO PROCESS. AND WHAT
THE OUTCOMES ARE- ONE OF THE
PROPOSALS ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR-
REQUEST IS. WE DO HAVE THE OF
OUR INVESTIGATORS HAVE THE
ABILITY TO. RESOLVE COMPLAINTS
WHILE THEY ARE IN THE
INVESTIGATIVE STATE IN ORDER TO
CONCILIATE AND SETTLE THEM SO.
BEING ABLE TO ALLOW THE
INVESTIGATORS MORE TIME WITH A
COMPLAINANT OR RESPONDENT IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO RESOLVE
THEIR COMPLAINTS SUCCESSFULLY
WOULD- CREATE BETTER OUTCOMES
FOR EVERYBODY INVOLVED RATHER
THAN JUST CLOSING CASES A
REFERRING THEM TO YOUR MEDI
MEDIATION OR LITIGATION. IF THE
RESOURCES WERE THERE AND THE
TIME WAS ALLOWED FOR THE
INVESTIGATORS TO BE ABLE TO WORK
WITH PEOPLE WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
HOPEFULLY IMPERII BE ABLE TO
SETTLEWORK SO WE CASES RATHER
THAN REFERRING THEM FOR.
PROSECUTION WILL THAT MAKES A
LOT OF SENSE NOW THESE
INDIVIDUALS WITH THE WILL OF THE
NEW P. WEISS THAT WILL BE
DEPLOYED FOR THIS PURPOSE. SO
WHAT WE REQUESTED IS A TEMPORARY
FUNDING- THERE WERE THREE YEARS
OF LIMITED TERM TEMPORARY
FUNDING- IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
GAUGE WHETHER OR NOT- NEED IS ON
GOING. THE INCREASE IN THE WAIT
TIMES THAT WE EXPERIENCED LAST
YEAR WHEN WE- RIGHT NOW ASSUME
MAY HAVE BEEN COVERED RELATED SO
IT MAY NOT BE AN ONGOING ISSUE.
AND OUR PROPOSAL REALLY IS TO
HIRE ADDITIONAL LIMITED TERM
STAFFING IN ORDER TO GET PAST
THE ISSUE NOW WHEN TO DECREASE
THE WAIT TIMES FROM THREE MONTHS
TO ONE MONTH. INCREASE THE
CONCILIATION AND THEN DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT WE NEED PERMANENT
RESOURCES GOING FORWARD. SURE
YOU OFFERED COBRE THE THAT'S THE
STANDARD- BLAME THAT ALWAYS GETS
PLACED ON IT EVERYTHING COVERT.
IN WHT MANNER HAS CALLED WITH
ADDED TO THE DEMANDS OF YOUR
WORKLOAD HOW HOW IS THAT MEETING
PEOPLE GOING TO SECOND GOING
OFF. WORK IN AND- YOU YOU HAD TO
BACK FILL OUR WHAT. SO WHEN I
REFERENCE CODE WHICH IN OUR WORK
WHAT IT REALLY REPRESENTED
ITSELF AS AN EMPLOYMENT CLAIMS-
WE HAD PEOPLE WHO WERE- SO MANY
COMPLAINTS THAT WERE BASED ON
WHETHER OR NOT THEY WERE
DISMISSED BECAUSE THEY WERE ILL
OR WHEN THE JOB MARKET RECOVERED
AFTER THE PANDEMIC WAS I WANNA
SAY OVER BUT NOW THAT THE
PANDEMIC IS. A SHIFTED COURSE.
NOW THAT THE JOB MARKET HAS
RECOVERED WE'VE SEEN AN INCREASE
IN EMPLOYMENT COMPLAINTS BECAUSE
PEOPLE HAVE RETURNED TO WORK IN
THE HOUSING REALM BECAUSE THERE
WERE MORE TRAINS THAT WERE
EITHER. EXPIRING OR WERE IN
DANGER OF EXPIRING AND WERE
COULD POTENTIALLY HAVE PEOPLE
LOSING THEIR HOMES WE
EXPERIENCED A SURGE IN
COMPLAINTS BECAUSE OF THAT. READ
MOSTLY RELATED OF PANDEMIC
BECAUSE THE MORATORIUMS WERE
RELATED TO HOPE IT DOES THAT
MAKE SENSE YES IT IS THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS SENATOR
NELSON. THANK YOU OKAY SENATOR
ROB YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS THIS
THE COUPLE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MAYBE THIS HAS BEEN ANSWERED AND
I JUST MISSED IT SO WHAT'S THE
IMPACT OF YOUR VACANCY RATE ON
YOUR BACKLOG INCREASE. SO WE
DURING COLD. WE DID HAVE AN
INCREASE IN OUR VACANCY RATE-
RIGHT NOW THE ENFORCEMENT
VACANCY RATE IS JUST A- HAIR
OVER THIRTEEN PERCENT. SO WE
HAVE INSTITUTED A CONTINUOUS JOB
POSTINGS FOR OUR INVESTIGATOR
POSITIONS IN BOTH EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING. WE ARE PULLING
APPLICATIONS ON A QUARTERLY
BASIS OUR FIRST CUT OFF WAS
JANUARY FIFTEENTH ANDWE HAD
ELEVEN HIRES FROM THAT EFFORT
WHICH WAS. MORE THAN HALF OF THE
VACANCIES. AND OUR SECOND KIND
OF JUST HAPPENED ON APRIL
FIFTEENTH. SO WE ANTICIPATE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO FILL OUR
REMAINING INVESTIGATOR VACANCIES
IN THE COMING MONTH- WE DO
ADVERTISING TRADE RECRUITING
MULTIPLE PLATFORMS BESIDES JUST
TELL EACH ARE IN OUR OWN
WEBSITE. WE POST ALL OF OUR
POSITIONS ON LINK THEN THROUGH
RECRUITER- AND WERE ADVERTISING
OPENINGS AT COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES NATIONWIDE THROUGH
A TOOL THAT. WE HAVE CALLED
SIMPLICITY. THANK YOU I ASSUME
THERE'S SOME SPOOL UP TIME. IN
TERMS OF TRAINING IN GETTING NEW
FOLKS UP TO SPEED UNLESS THEY'VE
PERFORMED IN THIS AREA IN SOME
OTHER FASHION FOR SOME OTHER
AGENTS HERE IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR SO I GUESS MY QUESTION IS
WHAT YOUR ROLLOUT PLANNED FOR
THE STAFFING INCREASES THAT WILL
RESULT FROM THIS. APPROPRIATION
NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO WHAT'S
YOUR TIME LINE TO GET FROM A
BACKLOG OF IT IF IT'S STILL TRUE
ABOUT FOUR MONTHS ON THE
EMPLOYMENT SIDE- TO ONE MONTH.
SO WITH THE WAIT TIME IN BOTH
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING RIGHT NOW
IS ABOUT THREE MONTHS- THERE YOU
ARE ABSOLUTELY CORRECT THERE IS
A BIT OF A SPLIT TIME WE HAVE TO
GET PEOPLE TRAINED- SO THE
TRAINING EFFORT THAT WE
UNDERTAKE TAKES ABOUT THREE
MONTHS- THAT'S- NOT THE END OF
IT THE MORE EXPERIENCED. A
PERSONAL THAT WE HAVE IF SOME OF
THEM HAVE BEEN DOING THIS FOR
YEARS IF NOT DECADES. SO THE YOU
KNOW CLEARLY SOMEONE WITH MORE
EXPERIENCE IS GOING TO BE ABLE
TO HANDLE MORE CASES AND DO THE
MORE QUICKLY. BUT WE ANTICIPATE
THAT WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO GET TO
THE ONE MONTH MARK WITHIN.
PROBABLY THREE TO SIX MONTHS OF
APPROVAL. THREE TO SIX MONTHS.
YES OKAY WE'RE NOT GOING AWAY SO
I GUESS WE'LL HAVE A CONTINUING
CONVERSATION ON THAT I HOPE
THAT'S TRUE- YOU ALL CERTAINLY
DO EXTRAORDINARY WORK OVER THERE
AND- I GUESS. I'LL SEE IF
ANYBODY CAN DO IT YOU CAN. SO
KEEP US POSTED THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. WE APPRECIATE THAT THANK
YOU SENATOR CAREER WOULD YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. ALL IGHT AS
YOU KNOW THIS IS A HOLD OPEN
ITEM- BUT- I DO I JUST WANT TO
ECHO THE QUESTIONS THAT SENATOR
ROTH ASTON MEAN THAT NUMBER IS
GOING DOWN ARE PREDICATED ON
FOLKS GETTING HIRED- AND BEING
TRAINED IN WANTING TO STAY IN. I
DON'T KNOW THAT YOU HAVE THE
CRYSTAL BALL FOR THAT BUT IF YOU
DO I HOPE YOU SHARE IT WITH
OTHER AGENCIES. WE APPRECIATE
THAT. THANK YOU SO NOW WE WILL
MOVE TO ANYONE WANTING TO
PROVIDE A PUBLIC COMMENT
REGARDING ITEMS ON THE AGENDA.
AS A REMINDER TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE SIX THREE. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS SEVEN THREE SIX. TWO
EIGHT THREE THREE. DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE LENGTH
OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE TEARS MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. TODAY I'M GOING TO
ASK THAT EACH MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC. PROVIDING CALMING KEEP
THEIR REMARKS TO ONE MINUTE.
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM SEEING NONE WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO- MODERATOR TO YOU AND
ASKING THAT YOU PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE PHONE.
CERTAINLY MANAGER IF YOU'D LIKE
TO PROVIDE A PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THE PHONE LINES PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MR MODERATOR AND CAN YOU ALSO
PLEASE GIVE ME THE NUMBER OF THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING
TO TESTIFY. CURRENTLY WE HAVE
THREE. OKAY THEN MISTER
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
AND CALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC INDIVIDUALLY SO THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE. THANK YOU WILL
BEGIN WITH LINE NUMBER TWENTY
SIX THAT'S TWO SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MICHAEL PIMENTEL
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION.
I JUST WANT TO COMMENT ON ISSUES
HE- RELATED TO HOMELESS. CAMP
AND RESOLUTION I AND I DO WANT
TO FLY THAT AS A LEGISLATURE IS
CONTEMPLATING. A SOLUTIONS FOR
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OTHER OPTION BECAUSE
BE HOME EIGHT FIVE TWO THE
CHALLENGES THAT ARE FACED BY
CALIFORNIA TRANSLATE. MUCH LIKE
OUR CITIES IN OUR COUNTY OUR
PUBLIC RIGHTS OF WAY ARE NOT
IMMUNE TO ISSUES RELATED TO
HOMELESSNESS AND WOULD
ENCOURAGE. THE LEGISLATURE COULD
CONTEMPLATE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
INCLUDING. PUBLIC TRANSIT
AGENCIES. IF YOU. FOR THE
DOLLARS THAT IT TAKES. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR. THANK YOU MISTER
CAN YOU COULD THE NEXT. OUR NEXT
CALLER COME FROM LINE TWENTY
THAT TO SAY YOUR LINE ITSELF.
GOOD MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FROM THE COLD WATER MAN
ON BEHALF OF SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF THE
HOMELESS ENCAMPMENT RESOLUTION
GRANT PROGRAM. LAFAYETTE FUNDING
PRIORITIZE BOTH URBAN AREAS AND
ENCAMPMENTS OF OVER FIFTY
PEOPLE. SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
IT'S THE LARGEST COUNTY IN THE
NATION COVERING OVER TWENTY
THOUSAND SQUARE MILES. OUR
COMMUNITY RANGE FROM HIGHLY
POPULATED TO REMOTE. HOMELESS
CAMPS IN OUR COUNTY ARE
FREQUENTLY LESS THAN FIFTY
PEOPLE AND ARE FOUND IN NON
URBAN AREAS SUCH AS DRIVERS
PERFECT AND THAT MOUNTAIN AREA.
WE HOPE THAT THE GUIDELINES THE
INCOMING CLEARING FUNDING WILL
ENABLE US TO ADDRESS OUR UNIQUE
HOMELESSNESS CHALLENGES AS WELL
AS THOSE IN OTHER. MORE URBAN
AREAS. OF THE STATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MATTER PLEASE
Q. UP THE NEXT CALLER. WE'LL GO
TO NEXT LINE WHICH IS MY NUMBER
TWENTY FOUR THAT'S TO FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ON THE WEB ON A MOMENT
CALIFORNIA RULE. FIFTEEN
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
ISSUE WE LOVE AND COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS AND STRATEGIC
COMMUNICATION. WE SUBMITTED OUR
COMMENTS IN WRITING TO THE
COMMITTEE WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT. TO WORKERS
ACTUALLY PAY FOR THE NATION WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND THE
LEGISLATURE IN YOUR COMMUNITY
AND NOT FINDING THE PROBLEM. AND
EFFECTIVE IMPLEMENTATION. OF THE
PROGRAM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. THIS TOMORROW I.
THREE P. WHO CALL IN AND YOU
SAID THERE WERE THREE L. LET ME
KNOW IF THERE ANY OTHERS ON THE
LINE. WE HAD ONE ADDITIONAL
ACUTE UP AFTERWARDS LOOK AT A
LINE NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT THAT'S
TWO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SHARE
GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE SCIENCES IMPORTANT ISSUE
FIVE THE PRECISION MEDICINE
PROPOSALS REQUIRE BY THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MISTER MODERATOR
ANYONE ELSE. I'M SURE THERE IS
NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME HOW GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH
SO HAVING HEARD FROM ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC SENATORS
NIELSEN CABALLERO A ROCK YOU
HAVE ANY FINAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. SEEING NONE ACTUALLY
EVERYONE IS RUSHING TO GET TO
THE MICROPHONE. WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO VOTE ONLY TO THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR- AND WE'RE GOING TO BE
SEPARATING THESE OUT INTO A FEW-
MOTIONS. SO DO WE HAVE A MOTION
ON THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR I
GUESS THIS IS GOING TO BE MOTION
ONE FOR ISSUES. ONE TWO THREE
FOUR SIX SEVEN NINE AND TEN WE
HAVE PULLED OUT ISSUES FIVE AND
EIGHT. ALL RIGHT THAT'S BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR ROTH- THE
MOTION IS TO ADOPT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS MR HACKER PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. KAMLAGER YES I
HAVE CABALLERO NIELSEN OFF. THAT
MOTION IS OUT FIVE ZERO- WE ARE
NOW GOING TO MOVE TO MOTION TO
WHICH IS ISSUE FIVE TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR DEPRESSION RESEARCH-
THIS IS THAT PRESERVE PRECISION
MEDICINE PROPOSALS SO MOVED BY
SENATOR RON- MR HACKER PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. KAMLAGER I
CABALLERO NIELSEN. ROTH. MR
HACKER THAT IS OUT. FOUR ONE YES
MANAGER WOULD WE WILL OPEN THE
ROLE IN THE RESEARCH AND THE
VOTE ON THE FIRST ITEM I WANT TO
BE RECORDED AS A NO NOT AND I.
OKAY WE WILL REFUND THE VOTE.
I'M AND WE WILL CALL THE ROLL
AGAIN I'D LIKE TO CAN WE SUSTAIN
THE MOTION- TO MOVE IT BY
SENATOR RON. OKAY GREAT THANK
YOU I MISS HER PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. KAMLAGER I CABALLERO
NIELSEN NO ROTH. THANK YOU
MANAGER THANK YOU VICE CHAIR SO
THAT MOTION IS OUT ON A FOUR ONE
VOTE- SO. THREE ONE. FOR MOTION
TO ONE. YES YES OKAY SO WE'RE ON
THE MOTION TO. THAT WAS MOVED BY
AND SENATOR ROTH ALREADY. WE
DIDN'T TAKE THE VOTE ON THAT YET. YES YOU DID. RIGHT. WE'RE
GOING TO REDO IT. OKAY MOTION TO
ISSUE FIVE TEN MILLION FOR
DEPRESSION RESEARCH THE SUSTAIN
MOTION TO MOVE IT BY SENATOR
RAFIU READY TO CALL THE ROLL
MISTER HACKER. GALLAGHER I
CABALLERO NIELSEN ROTH. OKAY
THAT MOTION IS OUT FIVE ZERO WE
ARE NOW MOVING ON TO MOTION
NUMBER THREE ALSO ISSUE FIVE FOR
NINE POINT TWO FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR HEALTH DISPARITIES
IS THERE A MOTION. SO MOVED BY
SENATOR ROTH MR HACKER PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL KAMLAGER HI
CARREIRO. NIELSEN ROTH. THAT
MOTIONS OUT. FOR ONE. THREE ONE
MILLION I KEEP THINKING THEY'RE
FIVE PEOPLE ON THIS. MY. YEAH I
KNOW WE MOVE ON TO MOTION FOR
ISSUE EIGHT FOUR THREE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR A BI EIGHT ONE NINE
DO WE HAVE MOTION. SO MOVED BY
SENATOR ROCK THANK YOU SENATOR
MR HACKER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
KAMLAGER I CABALLERO NIELSEN.
ROTH THAT MOTION CARRIES ON A
THREE ONE VOTE MY MATH IS BETTER
I ISSUE NUMBER FIVE MOTION
NUMBER FIVE I'M SORRY ISSUE
NUMBER EIGHT FIVE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR AB SIX EIGHTY IS THEIR
MOTION TO MOVE. SOME OF BY
SENATOR ROTH MR HACKER PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. KAMLAGER I
CABALLERO NIELSEN ROTH. THAT
MOTION CARRIES ON A THREE ONE
VOTE AND THEN WE HAVE MOTION SIX
ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT FOR FOUR
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR AB NINE TWO EIGHT IS
SO MOVED BY SENATOR ROB THANK
YOU MISTER HACKER PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL KAMLAGER I CABALLERO.
NIELSEN ROTH THAT MOTION CARRIES
ON A FOUR ZERO VOTE SO NOW WE
WILL MOVE TO MOTIONS SEVEN WHICH
IS ISSUE ITEM FOURTEEN THIS WAS
PART OF OUR DISCUSSION AB THAT
WAS FOR THE INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY WORKLOADS SUPPORT IS
THERE A MOTION SO MOVED BY
SENATOR ROB MR HACKER PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL CALL WATER HI
CABALLERO NIELSEN ROTH. THAT
MOTION CARRIES ON A THREE ONE
VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH IF ALL
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING HAVE VOTED
YES THAT HAS- WE'RE GONNA WE
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING ON CALL.
THANK YOU TO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU ARE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE OR YOU CAN
VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO
US. AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS THANK YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION IN
THIS THING CALLED DEMOCRACY I
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION WE HAVE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA FOR TODAY'S
HEARING THE SENATE BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE. FOR
IS ADJOURNED. WHERE SITE. IS
KIND OF. WEIRD I CAN HEREBY I'M
STILL ON- YOUR PUBLIC.